Henry, by the grace of God, king of France and England, to all who will see this present letter, greeting. It is sufficiently notorious and well known, how for some time past, a woman calling herself Joan the maid, abandoned women's clothes, and dressed and armed herself like a man, a thing against divine law, an abominable to God, and condemned and forbidden by every law. She committed cruel murders, and as reported, seduced and abused simple people by trying to convince them that she was sent by God and new heavenly secrets. While fostering these deceptions and engaging in hostilities against us and our people, she was captured fully armed by some of our loyal subjects, then brought to us as a prisoner. And because many have suspected and accused her of superstition, of spreading false dogmas, and of crimes of treason against divine majesty, we have been urgently entreated by the Reverend Father,
上帝恩典下的法国与英国国王亨利，致所有见到此信的人，问候。众所周知，一段时间以来，一个自称贞德的女子，抛弃了女性装束，像男人一样穿衣佩剑，这违背了神圣的法律，是上帝所憎恶的，也是一切法律所谴责和禁止的。她犯下了残酷的谋杀罪，据报道，她还试图说服单纯的民众相信她是上帝派来的，并拥有天上的秘密，以此诱骗和虐待他们。在助长这些欺骗行为并与我们及我们的人民为敌时，她被我们的一些忠诚臣民全副武装地俘获，随后作为囚犯被带到我们这里。由于许多人怀疑并指控她迷信、传播虚假教条以及犯有亵渎神圣尊严的叛国罪，我们已受到尊敬的父亲的紧急恳求，
our beloved and loyal counsellor, the Bishop of Beauvais, to surrender Joan to the Reverend Father for questioning and examination, so that after gathering a proper assembly, he can proceed against her, according to the rules and regulations of divine and canon law. So that was a proclamation issued on the 3rd of January 1431, and it was issued in the name of the nine-year-old king of France, Henri de, Henry II, who is better known in England as King Henry VI.
我们敬爱的忠诚顾问，博韦主教，要求将贞德移交给尊敬的父亲进行审讯和审查，以便在召集适当的会议后，他可以根据神圣法律和教会法的规则与条例对她进行起诉。这就是1431年1月3日发布的公告，它是以九岁的法国国王亨利·德·亨利二世的名义发布的，他在英国更广为人知的名字是亨利六世国王。
Now Henry had arrived in France in April 1429, and three months later, he had made a ceremonial entry into Ruon, where unfortunately Tom, Henry had not impressed the locals, had he? So we are in our final episode about Joan of Ark. And let's start with Henry the 6th, the hero of this story in many ways. So he had arrived, his little boy, he arrives in Rouen, and the French, sadly, don't really take to him, do they? Well, so Henry 6th is one of the great losers of English history.
亨利于1429年4月抵达法国，三个月后，他在鲁昂举行了仪式性的入城式，但遗憾的是，汤姆，亨利并没有给当地人留下深刻印象，对吧？所以我们现在是关于圣女贞德的最后一集。让我们从亨利六世开始，他在很多方面都是这个故事的主角。他抵达了，这个小男孩，他抵达了鲁昂，而法国人，可悲的是，并不真正喜欢他，不是吗？好吧，亨利六世是英国历史上伟大的失败者之一。
And I'm afraid that that kind of trend of being a loser begins early. because here he's, he's nine years old, he's arrived in Rouen at. He does not impress people at all, because the crowds have turned out to cheer him, and all he does is complain that they're making too much noise. He then heads straight into the castle and basically refuses to leave it. And by early January, when that edict that you read out is issued, he is still there. He's this kind of nervous, very uncharismatic, effectively invisible little boy. And this is a huge problem for the English regime in France, because they really need Henry to, you know, work a bit of the old royal magic to work the crowds, all that kind of thing,
恐怕这种失败者的趋势很早就开始了。因为他当时才九岁，他抵达鲁昂时，根本没有给人们留下任何印象，因为人群出来欢呼他，而他所做的只是抱怨他们制造了太大的噪音。然后他直接走进城堡，基本上拒绝离开。到一月初，当你读到的那道法令发布时，他仍然在那里。他就是那种神经质、非常缺乏魅力、实际上几乎隐形的小男孩。这对英国在法国的政权来说是一个巨大的问题，因为他们真的需要亨利，你知道，施展一点古老的皇家魔力来取悦人群，诸如此类的事情，
and Henry's simply refusing to play ball. To be fair, he's nine years old, so, I mean, it is what people call a big ask. Yeah, but I think you either have that sense for the stardust, or you don't, and Henry doesn't, unlike his father, Henry V, who absolutely did. So on the one hand, you have Henry, this nine-year-old little boy, cowering in the castle. Now, on the other hand, you have a rival claimant to the throne of France, don't you? Charles the 7th from the House of Valois.
而亨利根本拒绝配合。平心而论，他才九岁，所以，我的意思是，这在人们看来是一个很大的要求。是的，但我认为你要么有那种明星气质，要么没有，而亨利没有，不像他的父亲亨利五世，他绝对有。所以一方面，你有亨利，这个九岁的小男孩，蜷缩在城堡里。现在，另一方面，你有一位法国王位的竞争对手，不是吗？来自瓦卢瓦王朝的查理七世。
who for a few generations have been the royal dynasty of France and Charles the 7th having hitched his wagon to the star of Joan of Arc has been crowned king in the great cathedral at Grasse which is where the Valois kings are traditionally crowned and by doing that he has wormed his way into the hearts and minds of his French compatriots and actually this is a big kind of psychological blow in the struggle between these two characters for the French throne isn't it It is. And so the Duke of Bedford, who is Henry the 6th's regent in France, has decided, you know, if there's nothing for it, we're going to have to have a coronation for Henry as well to try and blot out the memory of Charles the 7th's coronation. And this is why he has basically been brought to France. However, there's a problem with this plan, because Rance is still under the control of Charles the 7th. So it's inaccessible to Henry the 6th. He can't go there and be crowned. And Paris,
几代以来，他们一直是法国的皇室王朝，查理七世将自己的命运与圣女贞德的明星光环联系在一起，并在兰斯大教堂加冕为王，那是瓦卢瓦国王传统上加冕的地方，通过这样做，他已经钻进了法国同胞的心里，实际上，这在争夺法国王位的两个角色之间的斗争中是一个巨大的心理打击，不是吗？确实如此。因此，亨利六世在法国的摄政王贝德福德公爵决定，你知道，如果别无选择，我们也必须为亨利举行加冕典礼，试图抹去查理七世加冕的记忆。这就是他基本上被带到法国的原因。然而，这个计划有一个问题，因为兰斯仍然在查理七世的控制之下。所以亨利六世无法进入那里。他不能去那里加冕。而巴黎，
which is the only conceivable alternative location for a coronation. I think Bedford feels it's in a very febrile state. Again, it's too risky at the moment to take Henry the 6th there. So the poor lad, I mean, he's useless, but you've got to feel for him. He's stuck in Rouen. It's an absolutely killing winter, completely bleak and freezing. And he's stuck there waiting for a coronation that it seems might never come. So, you know, all in all, it's very, it's very,
这是加冕典礼唯一可以想象的替代地点。我认为贝德福德觉得它处于一种非常狂热的状态。同样，目前带亨利六世去那里太冒险了。所以这个可怜的孩子，我的意思是，他毫无用处，但你不得不为他感到难过。他被困在鲁昂。这是一个绝对要命的冬天，完全荒凉且寒冷。他被困在那里等待一个似乎永远不会到来的加冕典礼。所以，总而言之，这非常，非常，
unfortunate. But this is not the only possible propaganda coup that the English have up their sleeves, is it? Because it's important to them basically to undermine the legitimacy of Charles the 7th. And if they can't get their own candidate into the cathedral to be crowned, one thing they can do is to cast doubt on Charles the 7th's coronation by basically saying the person who has arranged all this, the person who lies at the heart of his regime, is not privy to secrets from heaven through voices and angels, but basically as a witch is a figure of darkness. And this person is, of course, Joan the maid,
不幸。但这并不是英国人袖手旁观的唯一可能的宣传政变，是吗？因为对他们来说，破坏查理七世的合法性基本上很重要。如果他们不能让自己的候选人进入大教堂加冕，他们能做的一件事就是通过基本上说安排这一切的人，即处于他政权核心的人，不是通过声音和天使获得天上的秘密，而是基本上是一个女巫，是一个黑暗的人物，来对查理七世的加冕产生怀疑。而这个人当然就是贞德，
who we heard about in the introduction, Joan of Arc, because she's now fallen into English hands. She has. She's been sold by a Burgundian nobleman to the English, and we heard at the end of the previous episode that she'd arrived in Rouen on the 23rd of December 14th. 30 and she had been handed over to the guy who is the current captain of the castle in Rouen. And this is a very formidable man, a guy who makes a very formidable jailer.
我们在介绍中听到的圣女贞德，因为她现在落入了英国人手中。确实如此。她被一位勃艮第贵族卖给了英国人，我们在上一集结尾听说她于1430年12月23日抵达鲁昂，并被移交给了目前鲁昂城堡的队长。这是一个非常可怕的人，一个非常可怕的狱卒。
He is Richard Beauchamp, the Earl of Warwick. And he had been a very close friend of Henry V. Henry V. Henry V wasn't a guy given to friendship, but he liked Warwick. And Warwick therefore feels a kind of personal responsibility, I think, to Henry the sixth and had arrived in France essentially at the head of the young king's escort. And in the words of a contemporary, he was a man of impressive bearing, exceptional judgment and great military experience. And as such, he perfectly understands the urgent need to make an
他是理查德·博尚，沃里克伯爵。他曾是亨利五世的密友。亨利五世不是一个容易交朋友的人，但他喜欢沃里克。因此，沃里克感到对亨利六世有一种个人责任感，我认为，他基本上是作为这位年轻国王的护卫队首领抵达法国的。用一位当代人的话说，他是一个举止令人印象深刻、判断力非凡且具有丰富军事经验的人。因此，他完全理解将贞德的审判变成一场国际盛事的迫切需要。
international spectacle of James' trial. He knows that this has to be done on the stage of not just France, but of the whole of Christendom. But if that's going to happen, he has to keep a tight leash on her. Because she's already tried to escape, hasn't she, twice? And the second time, if I remember correctly, she jumped out of a 60-foot tower and basically only damaged her back or something. Got very badly concast. I mean, yeah, I'm not entirely sure, and this is the Middle Ages. So, I don't know. But Warwick is not going to let anything like that happen on his watch. So the moment Joan has arrived in Rouen, she's taken straight to the city's castle, which is the absolute nerve centre of English rule, not just in Normandy, but probably now by France,
他知道这不仅要在法国的舞台上，而且要在整个基督教世界的舞台上进行。但如果这要发生，他必须严密监视她。因为她已经尝试过逃跑，不是吗，两次？如果我没记错的话，第二次她从一座60英尺高的塔上跳下来，基本上只是伤了背部之类的。摔得非常严重。我的意思是，是的，我不完全确定，这是中世纪。所以，我不知道。但沃里克不会让这种事情在他的监视下发生。所以贞德一到鲁昂，就被直接带到了城市的城堡，这是英国统治的绝对神经中枢，不仅在诺曼底，可能现在在法国也是如此，
because Paris has become so unstable. And of course, it's the very place where Henry VI is staying. But Joan's quarters are obviously much less luxurious than the kings. She is immured in a large, cold, unfurnished cell in one of the towers of the castle. and it only has two very narrow arrow slits to let in the light. So it's a very kind of grim place to be kept. And in this cell, she is shackled by her ankles to a huge wooden beam. There are four English guards on rotation, keeping watch over her day and night. And Warwick forbids anyone to talk to her without permission.
因为巴黎变得太不稳定了。当然，这正是亨利六世居住的地方。但贞德的住处显然比国王的要简陋得多。她被关在城堡塔楼里一个又大又冷、没有家具的牢房里。它只有两个非常狭窄的箭孔来透光。所以这是一个非常阴森的地方。在这个牢房里，她的脚踝被锁在一根巨大的木梁上。有四名英国卫兵轮流日夜监视她。沃里克禁止任何人在没有许可的情况下与她交谈。
So she is absolutely not, for instance, getting any legal advice. And this point about legal advice is important, of course, because the English authorities from the outset are determined that she will go on trial, she will be convicted, and she will be put to death. And this, as we discussed last time, is not purely a question of kind of cynical policy. They genuinely believe that she is a witch and that she represents something diabolical, don't they? Yeah, I mean, I think Bedford especially does and Warwick does as well. And this sense that they are dealing perhaps with satanic powers is one of the factors that has influenced them in agreeing to outsource legal proceedings to the ecclesiastical authorities. And specifically, as we heard in the edict that you read out from issued in the name of Henry the 6th, she is going to be transferred for trial to the Bishop of the Sea. in which Joan had first been taken prisoner. So to quote that edict, our beloved and loyal counsellor,
所以她绝对没有，例如，得到任何法律建议。关于法律建议的这一点当然很重要，因为英国当局从一开始就决心让她受审、定罪并被处死。正如我们上次讨论的那样，这不仅仅是一个愤世嫉俗的政策问题。他们真诚地相信她是一个女巫，她代表着某种恶魔般的东西，不是吗？是的，我的意思是，我认为贝德福德尤其是这样，沃里克也是。这种他们可能正在处理撒旦力量的感觉是影响他们同意将法律程序外包给教会当局的因素之一。具体来说，正如我们在以亨利六世名义发布的法令中所听到的那样，她将被移交给贞德最初被俘虏的教区主教进行审判。所以引用那道法令，我们敬爱的忠诚顾问，
the Bishop of Beauvais, and this is a guy we've heard of before, Pierre Caution. So Pierre Couchon is going to preside over this. It's important to say, isn't it? It's not a trial, as we would understand it. You know, people aren't shouting, objection, Your Honor, and all of this kind of carry on. Yeah, there's no jury or anything like that.
博韦主教，这就是我们之前听说过的人，皮埃尔·科雄。所以皮埃尔·科雄将主持这次审判。重要的是要说，不是吗？这不是我们所理解的审判。你知道，人们不会大喊，反对，法官大人，以及所有这些事情。是的，没有陪审团之类的东西。
No, it is a, this is an ecclesiastical court, and it is literally an inquisition, an investigation into suspected heresy. And we'll talk us through some of the procedure because the procedure has been established over the last couple of centuries, hasn't it? And this isn't necessarily a show trial. I mean, people take this stuff very seriously. Yeah, and there's a very precise format by now for inquisitions. So the initial responsibility of the judges, Caution is one.
不，这是一个教会法庭，它实际上是一个宗教裁判所，是对涉嫌异端邪说的调查。我们将讨论一些程序，因为程序在过去几个世纪里已经建立起来了，不是吗？这不一定是一场作秀审判。我的意思是，人们非常认真地对待这些事情。是的，现在宗教裁判所已经有了一个非常精确的格式。所以法官的初步责任，科雄是其中之一。
They are also in due course going to recruit a local head of the Dominican prior to be the second judge. Their responsibility is clear. They have to establish that the person who is going to be sent to trial has a reputation so shocking, so pestiferous, that it positively demands to be investigated. And in the case of Joan, this is seen as being a very simple matter because she, by this point, has become easily the most famous woman in Christendom, perhaps, you know, the most famous person full stop.
他们也将在适当的时候招募一位当地的多米尼加修道院院长作为第二位法官。他们的责任很明确。他们必须确定被送去审判的人的名声是如此令人震惊，如此具有传染性，以至于它确实需要被调查。在贞德的案例中，这被视为一件非常简单的事情，因为她到目前为止已经成为基督教世界中最著名的女性，也许，你知道，最著名的人，句号。
So to quote a German theologian contemporary, such wonders Joan has performed that not just France, but every Christian kingdom stands amazed. So this trial is going to be massive news, whatever happens. But it also means that on the 9th of January, when Couchon indicts Joan as a woman of what he calls Marla Farmer, so notoriety, he can take it as read that everyone knows what she's done. He doesn't have to kind of adduce it. He doesn't have to justify it. and he draws up two particular accounts of heretical behaviour. The first is, to quote the charge sheet, that Joan had dared to perform to speak and to publicise many things contrary to the Catholic faith
所以引用一位德国神学家当代人的话，贞德创造了如此奇迹，不仅是法国，而且每个基督教王国都感到惊讶。所以无论发生什么，这次审判都将是巨大的新闻。但也意味着在1月9日，当科雄指控贞德为一个他称之为“Marla Farmer”的女人，即臭名昭著时，他可以认为每个人都知道她做了什么。他不必引用它。他不必证明它。他起草了关于她异端行为的两项具体指控。第一项是，引用指控书，贞德竟敢表演、谈论和宣传许多违背天主教信仰的事物，
and injurious to its articles. Secondly, that utterly disregarding the honour due to the female sex, throwing off the bridle of modesty and forgetting all female decency, she wore the disgraceful clothing of men a shocking and vile monstrosity. And these two trials signal what over the course of Jones trial are going to be the main focus of Couchon's investigations. So specifically, the truth or otherwise of Jones claims to have received direct communication from the heaven. So in other words, the validity or otherwise of her voices. And secondly, what Couchon sees as her absolutely mulish insistence on wearing male dress,
并损害其条款。其次，完全无视女性应有的荣誉，抛弃了谦虚的缰绳，忘记了所有的女性体面，她穿着可耻的男性服装，这是一种令人震惊和卑鄙的怪物行为。这两项审判标志着在贞德审判过程中科雄调查的主要焦点。具体来说，贞德声称收到来自天堂的直接交流的真实性与否。换句话说，她声音的有效性与否。其次，科雄所看到的她对穿着男性服装的绝对固执的坚持，
which is directly contrary to biblical injunctions. It's interesting that that issue about male dress looms so large, doesn't it? It does for reasons that we'll come to in the course of the trial. So before that, Caution has to pile up all of this evidence and all of these documents and stuff. And this goes to the point about whether or not this is just a show trial by a kangaroo court. And I believe a lot of scholars now argue that that's to do it in injustice, that actually this is a much more serious and painstaking proceeding than is popularly imagined. Is that right?
这直接违背了圣经的禁令。有趣的是，关于男性服装的问题显得如此重要，不是吗？确实如此，原因我们将在审判过程中谈到。在此之前，科雄必须堆积所有这些证据和所有这些文件之类的东西。这涉及到这是否仅仅是一场袋鼠法庭的作秀审判。我相信现在许多学者认为这是一种不公正，实际上这比人们普遍想象的要严肃和艰苦得多。是这样吗？
Well, and not just popularly imagined, but van is normal in an inquisition. It is incredibly detailed and forensic. So to quote Daniel Hobbins, who published this translation of all the documents relating to Jones trial into English, and he emphasizes in his introduction to that collection, the degree to which Couchon is not, you know, he is not trampling on the record. recognized procedures in an inquisition. Absolutely on the contrary, he is going to inordinate pains to ensure that the rules are very, very strictly followed.
嗯，不仅是普遍想象的，而且在宗教裁判所中是正常的。它非常详细和法医化。所以引用丹尼尔·霍宾斯的话，他出版了所有关于贞德审判的文件到英语中，他在该合集的引言中强调了科雄在多大程度上没有，你知道，他没有践踏宗教裁判所中公认的程序。恰恰相反，他正在付出极大的努力来确保规则得到非常、非常严格的遵守。
And this is why we have all the many documents that we do relating to Jones' trial, to quote Hobbins, Coachon believed his role in the trial would bear examination from even hostile observers. And because he knows that, you know, there is, we've said there's going to be massive, massive international interest in this case. That's the whole point of doing it. So he knows that he can't afford to cut corners because otherwise he will get criticism. Everything has to be done precisely by the book.
这就是为什么我们有所有关于贞德审判的许多文件，引用霍宾斯的话，科雄相信他在审判中的角色即使受到敌对观察者的审查也能经得起考验。因为他知道，你知道，正如我们所说，这个案件将会有巨大的、巨大的国际兴趣。这就是做这件事的全部意义。所以他知道他不能走捷径，否则他会受到批评。一切都必须完全按照书本进行。
And so this is why, even though Couchon had indicted Joan on the 9th of January, he then spends about six weeks making sure that everything is in absolutely perfect order before the trial itself actually begins. So they send investigators, don't they, to Jones' home village of Don Remy, which is a difficult task because, as we discussed, It's a liminal space. It's full of bandits and it's now full of French, basically. So it's a dangerous place for his investigators to go.
这就是为什么，尽管科雄在1月9日指控了贞德，但他随后花了大约六周时间确保在审判本身真正开始之前一切都绝对完美。所以他们派调查员去贞德的家乡多姆雷米，这是一项艰巨的任务，因为正如我们讨论的那样，这是一个临界空间。它到处都是土匪，现在基本上到处都是法国人。所以这对他的调查员来说是一个危险的地方。
And poor Joan has been subject to a lot of physical examinations. And now she has yet another one by the Duke of Bedford's wife, the Duchess of Bedford, to check again whether she is a virgin or not. And she still is. So she passes that test at any rate. Yeah. And meanwhile, Couchon is drawing up all of these lists of questions and stuff, isn't he? And he's hiring people.
可怜的贞德受到了许多身体检查。现在她又接受了贝德福德公爵夫人的另一次检查，再次检查她是否是处女。她仍然是。所以无论如何她通过了那个测试。是的。与此同时，科雄正在起草所有这些问题清单之类的东西，不是吗？他正在雇佣人。
so officials and inquisitors and whatnot. Yes, so a huge number of advisors, assessors, examiners, theologians, expert witnesses, all these kind of people are being lined up. And in fact, over the course of the trial, 131 lawyers, theologians, priests, abbots, end up participating in it. And the kind of amazing fact for people who think
官员和宗教裁判官等等。是的，大量的顾问、评估员、审查员、神学家、专家证人，所有这些人都被排成一行。事实上，在审判过程中，131名律师、神学家、牧师、修道院院长最终参与了其中。对于那些认为
that this is an English kangaroo court, all but eight of these 131 figures are French. That's so surprising. And of those eight, only three are English. It's a lawyer and two theologians from Oxford. Now, that really is a twist, because I'd always assume this was a completely English-run affair. And actually, but these are French people who are,
这是一场英国袋鼠法庭的人来说，一个惊人的事实是，这131个人物中除了八个以外都是法国人。这太令人惊讶了。而在那八个人中，只有三个是英国人。这是一名律师和两名来自牛津的神学家。现在，这确实是一个转折，因为我一直以为这是一场完全由英国人经营的事务。实际上，但这些是法国人，他们是，
they're part of Henry the Sixth Party, his faction, as it were. Are they? Yeah, all loyal to the Burgundians. They genuinely think that Henry is, appointed by God. They accept the Treaty of Toire. They think that Charles the 7th is an imposter, usurper. So they are all in. Right. Well, they send out tremendous people. So the 20th of February, Couchon is ready and he delivers this formal summons to Joan, telling her, you have to appeal before the tribunal the following day. And so at 8 o'clock
他们是亨利六世党派的一部分，也就是他的派系。是吗？是的，都忠于勃艮第人。他们真诚地认为亨利是由上帝任命的。他们接受《特鲁瓦条约》。他们认为查理七世是一个冒名顶替者、篡位者。所以他们都全力以赴。好吧，他们派出了了不起的人。所以2月20日，科雄准备好了，他向贞德发出了正式传票，告诉她，你必须在第二天出现在法庭上。所以8点
on the morning, the 21st of February, this very dramatic day begins. Yes. So Joan is led down from her cell up in the tower and she's led out into a courtyard and taken to the chapel of the castle in Rouen. And this is where Couchon and the assessors are gathered. And of course, you know, we've said how the apparatus of this trial is very French, but the security is definitely provided by the English. So there are English guards everywhere. And the Earl of Warwick is a kind of constant lurking presence in the background.
在2月21日的早晨，这非常戏剧性的一天开始了。是的。所以贞德被从塔楼的牢房里带下来，被带到一个庭院里，带到了鲁昂城堡的礼拜堂。这就是科雄和评估员聚集的地方。当然，你知道，我们已经说过这次审判的机构是非常法国化的，但安全确实是由英国人提供的。所以到处都是英国卫兵。沃里克伯爵在背景中是一种持续潜伏的存在。
he is definitely keeping an eye on proceedings. So Joan is brought in for her trial. She is still dressed in male clothes. Her dark hair is still cropped short. And although obviously she hasn't been getting much sunlight because her cell only has those two arrow slits, she impresses people, I think, with her bearing. She looks resolute.
他绝对在监视诉讼程序。所以贞德被带进来受审。她仍然穿着男装。她的黑发仍然剪得很短。虽然显然她没有得到多少阳光，因为她的牢房只有那两个箭孔，但我认为她以她的举止给人们留下了深刻印象。她看起来很坚定。
She looks unbowed. But you know, she's a teenage girl. and she is being brought into this room full of men, all of whom are much older than her, and of course, who are infinitely her superiors in learning. So Joan, you know, we've said she was raised peasant, she's illiterate, she has no expertise in theology. She has no familiarity with the kind of moral and metaphysical terms that her judges and her assessors are going to be bandying around.
她看起来没有屈服。但你知道，她是一个十几岁的女孩。她被带进这个满是男人的房间，所有人都比她大得多，当然，在学识上无限地优于她。所以贞德，你知道，我们说过她是农民出身，她是文盲，她没有神学方面的专业知识。她不熟悉她的法官和评估员将要讨论的道德和形而上学术语。
And she has no real understanding of the, legal procedures in which she is now ensnared. She has the vocabulary. She has the modes of expression of a peasant, a very smart, intelligent, often sassy peasant. But, you know, she is, she is not a scholar from the University of Paris. And these are the, you know, the guys that she is facing. And I think it is an incredibly Kafkaesque environment because, you know, we've said she doesn't have a defence lawyer. She's going to have to effectively conduct her own defence. She has all these kind of guys who are large numbers of people who are just firing questions at her. There's never a single topic.
她对她现在陷入的法律程序也没有真正的理解。她有词汇。她有农民的表达方式，一个非常聪明、机智、经常厚颜无耻的农民。但是，你知道，她不是巴黎大学的学者。而这些是，你知道，她面对的人。我认为这是一个令人难以置信的卡夫卡式的环境，因为，你知道，我们说过她没有辩护律师。她将不得不有效地进行自己的辩护。她有所有这些，你知道，大量的人只是向她开火。从来没有一个单一的话题。
They're always coming at her at different angles. There isn't any continuity of the personnel. You know, one judge will be there one day, gone the next. I mean, incredibly bewildering for her, I think, and intimidating. But right from the start, she displays an astonishing degree of self-possession of spirit. And to read the trial proceedings, I think it is impossible not to be incredibly impressed by her. So it starts by, Couchon tells her, you must swear an oath on the Gospels to tell the truth. And she kind of lays down a marker right from the beginning, doesn't she?
他们总是从不同的角度向她走来。人员没有任何连续性。你知道，一位法官有一天会在那里，第二天就走了。我的意思是，我认为这对她来说非常令人困惑，而且令人生畏。但从一开始，她就表现出令人惊讶的自我控制精神。阅读审判记录，我认为不可能不被她深深打动。所以它开始时，科雄告诉她，你必须在福音书上宣誓说实话。她从一开始就设定了一个标记，不是吗？
Because she says, I don't know what you wish to ask me. Perhaps you might ask me things I can't tell you. So what are these things that she can't tell him? Well, there's a number of things, but absolutely top of the list is her voices. and she tells Couchon, you know, I'm very happy to answer questions about my parents or about, you know, everything that I've been doing since I left their house. But, and to quote her, the revelations to her from God, as she defined those voices, she is saying, you know, that's a different matter. They are off limits. And she goes on to explain that she had only ever talked about these voices to Charles Seventh.
因为她说，我不知道你想问我什么。也许你可能会问我一些我不能告诉你的事情。那么这些她不能告诉他的事情是什么呢？嗯，有很多事情，但绝对排在首位的是她的声音。她告诉科雄，你知道，我很高兴回答关于我的父母或者关于，你知道，我离开他们家以来所做的一切的问题。但是，引用她的话，上帝对她的启示，正如她定义那些声音一样，她说，你知道，那是另一回事。它们是禁区。她继续解释说，她只对查理七世谈论过这些声音。
And she doesn't believe that she is permitted by heaven to discuss them. and she specifies, you know, I am not allowed to talk about them, even were it necessary to cut off my head. And she then tells Couchon, you know, but I might be able to in eight days time. What's happening in eight days time? Well, it's obviously a number that she's kind of snatching from the void. The voices have promised to get back to her by eight days. Yeah, the voices will get back to her, exactly. Wow.
她不相信天堂允许她讨论它们。她具体说明，你知道，我不被允许谈论它们，即使必须砍掉我的头。然后她告诉科雄，你知道，但我可能在八天后能做到。八天后会发生什么？嗯，这显然是她从虚空中抓到的一个数字。声音承诺在八天内回到她身边。是的，声音会回到她身边，完全正确。哇。
And Couchon had not been expecting this, but, you know, he's not having any of it. And in the days that follow, he and the assessors are just harrying and chivying Joan relentlessly to try and force her to talk about the voices. Right. So Joan adopts different tactics, doesn't she, to keep the inquisters obey. So one of them, nice cricketing metaphor for you, Tom. She plays a dead bat. Next question. Often she says, certainly the beginning, she says this thing, you know, this is just between me and God. I'm not going to tell you everything for I don't have permission. But then she changes the strategy at times, doesn't she? She talks, she says, well, you need to talk to somebody else.
科雄没有预料到这一点，但是，你知道，他没有接受。在接下来的日子里，他和评估员们只是无情地骚扰和催促贞德，试图强迫她谈论这些声音。好吧。所以贞德采取了不同的策略，不是吗，来保持审判官的服从。所以其中之一，为你提供一个很好的板球隐喻，汤姆。她打了一个死球。下一个问题。通常她说，当然是开始时，她说这件事，你知道，这只是我和上帝之间的事。我不会告诉你一切，因为我没有许可。但后来她有时会改变策略，不是吗？她谈论，她说，好吧，你需要和别人谈谈。
You need to talk to the scholars who investigated me in Poitiers. Remember we talked about that, where it was sort of like a kind of viver she had by Charles the Seventh's churchman. And there's such a kind of touching degree of naivitish to that to imagine that the scholars in English Ruor would ever go and consult the scholars in Valois-Puayéé. you know, it's kind of a reminder that she doesn't entirely have a handle on the politics of it all, I think. And also, I mean, having said that she's not absolutely got her finger on the pulse of the politics, I mean, she does have this incredible kind of
你需要和在普瓦捷调查我的学者谈谈。记得我们谈过那个吗，在那里，这就像查理七世的教士对她进行的一种审查。那种天真程度非常感人，想象一下英国鲁昂的学者会去咨询瓦卢瓦普瓦捷的学者。你知道，这提醒人们她并没有完全掌握这一切的政治，我认为。而且，我的意思是，话虽如此，她并没有完全掌握政治的脉搏，我的意思是，她确实有这种令人难以置信的
earthy common sense of a peasant. If you were a 19th century historian, you'd call it. But she, you know, she's started kind of being badgered by Kosher and said, you've got to tell us everything. And she responds as a saying among little children that people are and hanged for telling the truth. You know, and she's not wrong there. But basically, there are 15 sessions of interrogation, and they are exhausting, and they are kind of merciless. And over time, she begins to concede more and more ground.
农民的朴实常识。如果你是19世纪的历史学家，你会称之为。但是她，你知道，她开始被科雄纠缠，说，你必须告诉我们一切。她回应说，小孩子中间有一句谚语，人们因为说真话而被绞死。你知道，她在那点上没错。但基本上，有15次审讯，它们令人筋疲力尽，而且它们是无情的。随着时间的推移，她开始让步越来越多。
She does. So already, by the second session, so remember in the first sessions, she said, I'm not going to talk about voices, by the second session, she's already doing that. She's starting to talk about how she first heard them, how she'd known that it was an angel speaking to her. So all the details that we mentioned in our first episode describing how Joan came to hear the voices, back in Don Remy, this is where those details come from.
她确实让步了。所以，到第二次会议时，所以记住在第一次会议中，她说，我不会谈论声音，到第二次会议时，她已经在这样做了。她开始谈论她是如何第一次听到它们的，她是如何知道是一个天使在对她说话的。所以我们第一集中提到的所有细节，描述贞德是如何在多姆雷米听到声音的，这些细节就是从这里来的。
And then in the third session, she reveals that the voice is still very much a presence. It's still very much with her. So she tells Couchon and the rest of the court that she had heard the voice three times the previous day. And she specifies, once in the morning, once at Vespers, and a third time when the best of the best of the. bell rang for the Hail Mary at night. And people may remember that the very first time back in Don Rehmi when she heard the ringing of bells, she reveals that the voice had woken her up in the morning while she lay sleeping.
然后在第三次会议中，她透露声音仍然非常存在。它仍然非常与她在一起。所以她告诉科雄和法庭的其他成员，她前一天听到了三次声音。她具体说明，一次在早上，一次在晚祷时，第三次是在晚上为圣母经敲钟时。人们可能记得，回到多姆雷米第一次听到钟声时，她透露声音在早上她睡觉时叫醒了她。
And she also says that she had asked it for its advice on how best to deal with her interrogators. And she says, The voice told me to answer boldly and God would help me. And then in the fourth session, so that was the third session, in the fourth session, we get a real bombshell, don't we? Because for the first time, she says, I know where the voice comes from,
她还说，她曾向它寻求关于如何最好地处理审讯者的建议。她说，声音告诉我大胆回答，上帝会帮助我。然后在第四次会议中，所以那是第三次会议，在第四次会议中，我们得到了一个真正的重磅炸弹，不是吗？因为她第一次说，我知道声音来自哪里，
I know what the voice is. It is the voice of St. Catherine and St. Margaret, and their forms are crowned with beautiful crowns in rich and precious fashion. So remind listeners Tom, St. Catherine of Catherine Wheel Firework Fame had been martyred, but for refusing to surrender her virginity.
我知道声音是什么。它是圣凯瑟琳和圣玛格丽特的声音，她们的形象戴着美丽的皇冠，以丰富和珍贵的方式。所以提醒听众汤姆，以凯瑟琳轮烟花闻名的圣凯瑟琳因拒绝放弃贞洁而殉道。
And St. Margaret exactly the same, and a further detail, St. Margaret had been so fired with the love of the gospel that she had dressed up as a man to smuggle herself into a monastery. Right. Very, yeah, very suggestive. So there's an emphasis there on virginity and on cross-dressing, which people may feel is perhaps psychologically significant. And then shortly after that bombshell, there's another bombshell because she describes, again, in detail, the very first time she heard the voice back in Don Rehmi. And she reveals who precisely had been behind that voice, to quote her,
圣玛格丽特完全一样，还有一个细节，圣玛格丽特对福音的热爱如此强烈，以至于她打扮成男人混进了一座修道院。对。非常，是的，非常具有暗示性。所以这里强调了贞洁和异装，人们可能会觉得这在心理上可能很重要。在那之后不久，又有一个重磅炸弹，因为她再次详细描述了她回到多姆雷米第一次听到声音的时候。她透露了究竟是谁在那个声音背后，引用她的话，
I saw St. Michael before my eyes, and he was not alone, but was well attended by angels from heaven. So St. Michael, the captain, the archangel, who is the captain of heaven, the great patron of French resistance to the English. It's St. Michael, also who had spoken to her. So you've got St. Catherine, St. Margaret, St. Michael.
我亲眼看到了圣迈克尔，他并不孤单，但有来自天堂的天使陪同。所以圣迈克尔，队长，大天使，他是天堂的队长，法国抵抗英国的伟大守护神。也是圣迈克尔对她说话。所以你有圣凯瑟琳，圣玛格丽特，圣迈克尔。
So you mentioned the great historian, Johann Housinger, and this argument that basically this is the first, time it's occurred to her who the voices are that previously she didn't know. Yeah, so to quote Husinga, it seems plausible to me that it was only fairly late, perhaps even only during her trial, that Joan linked her inspirations to the figures she knew best and cherished most among the saints. And so these saints, you know, she would have viewed them almost as her intimates. And I guess what Husinger is suggesting is that under the pressure of this interrogation,
所以你提到了伟大的历史学家约翰·胡辛加，以及这个论点，基本上这是她第一次意识到声音是谁，之前她不知道。是的，所以引用胡辛加的话，对我来说，贞德直到相当晚，也许甚至直到审判期间，才将她的灵感与她在圣徒中最了解和最珍视的人物联系起来，这似乎是合理的。所以这些圣徒，你知道，她会把他们几乎视为她的密友。我想胡辛加所暗示的是，在这次审讯的压力下，
She reaches for these saints almost as metaphors for the voices. You know, she is being harried and harried and harried and she's desperate to try and put into words, to explain to her inquisitors what the voices mean to her, why she loves them, why she trusts them, why these voices bring her consolation. And so she turns to the saints that she loved best. And I think that what you get in this testimony from Joan is a sense that she is trying to understand. what she's been having and definitely her inquisitors
她几乎把这些圣徒当作声音的隐喻。你知道，她被不断地骚扰、骚扰、再骚扰，她拼命想用语言表达，向她的审讯者解释这些声音对她意味着什么，为什么她爱它们，为什么她信任它们，为什么这些声音给她带来安慰。所以她转向了她最爱的圣徒。我认为你在贞德的证词中得到的是一种感觉，即她正在试图理解。她一直在经历什么，而且毫无疑问她的审讯者
are struggling to understand as well because there is a real sense in which what Jones' testimony reveals is an experience of the supernatural that is fundamentally unlike most other testimonies from
也在努力理解，因为确实有一种感觉，即贞德的证词揭示了一种超自然的体验，这与大多数其他来自
visionaries from people who claim to have heard or witnessed the saints. So like Catherine of Siena who mentioned before. So it's not like that. It's different. It's more, more, more concrete, more... Less abstract, I think. Right.
远见者，来自声称听到或目睹圣徒的人的证词根本不同。所以就像之前提到的锡耶纳的凯瑟琳。所以它不像那样。它不同。它更，更，更具体，更……我认为不那么抽象。对。
Joan is not a girl for abstractions. So on the one hand, Joan is absolutely convinced that her voices do come from heavenly entities, that they are independent of her, that they are exterior of her, that, you know,
贞德不是一个喜欢抽象的女孩。所以一方面，贞德绝对相信她的声音确实来自天上的实体，它们独立于她，它们外在于她，你知道，
they are not rising up from inside her, from her head or whatever. On the other hand, and this I think is what distinguishes her from most visionaries, she's incredibly matter-of-fact about them.
它们不是从她内心，从她的头脑或其他什么地方升起的。另一方面，我认为这使她与大多数远见者区别开来，她对它们非常务实。
They are as real to her as her parents had been or, you know, her friends back in Don Remy. So Cautier asks her, did St. Margaret speak English? And Joan thinks this is a ridiculous question. She laughs. Why should she speak English? She's not on the side of the English. And then again, she's asked, well, what about St. Michael?
它们对她来说就像她的父母或者，你知道，她在多姆雷米的朋友一样真实。所以科雄问她，圣玛格丽特说英语吗？贞德认为这是一个荒谬的问题。她笑了。她为什么要说英语？她不在英国人这一边。然后再次，她被问到，好吧，圣迈克尔呢？
Did, you know, was he clothed or was he naked? And Joan answers, well, ridiculous question. Of course God can clothe St. Michael. And so I think it's unsurprising that her judges, who perhaps are, too attuned to abstractures and to notions of the supernatural and theology and so on, they really struggled to get a handle on the kind of the vividness of just how real these voices are to Joan. Interesting. They don't think that Joan is making this up. I think there is one inquisitor who does think this, who does think that she is deluded.
你知道，他是穿衣服的还是裸体的？贞德回答说，好吧，荒谬的问题。上帝当然可以给圣迈克尔穿衣服。所以我认为她的法官们，他们可能太适应抽象和超自然和神学的概念等等，他们真的很难掌握这些声音对贞德来说是多么真实，这并不奇怪。有趣。他们不认为贞德是在编造。我想有一位审讯者确实这样认为，他确实认为她被迷惑了。
I mean, it's not unheard of for teenage girls to make up stuff. No, it is interesting. And I think when you read her testimony, you can see why they why they would believe that. Because Joan is speaking with an utter conviction. And although we haven't really heard her in her own voice before that, except when she writes it dictates her letters, I think the way in which she convinces people that what she's saying is true, whether it be the king or her fellow captains or the common soldiers or whatever,
我的意思是，十几岁的女孩编造事情并非闻所未闻。不，这很有趣。我认为当你阅读她的证词时，你可以看出为什么他们会相信这一点。因为贞德说话时带着绝对的信念。虽然我们之前没有真正听到她自己的声音，除了她写下或口述她的信件时，我认为她让人们相信她所说的是真实的方式，无论是国王还是她的同僚队长或普通士兵或其他什么人，
there is an intensity and a conviction that is very convincing. Now, of course, the issue then, once that is accepted, is if these voices are real, then what are they? It is impossible for the inquisitors in Ruor to accept what Joan is insisting that they are of heavenly origin, because of course, this is a political trial, and if they accept that these voices are of heavenly origin,
有一种强度和信念，非常令人信服。现在，当然，一旦被接受，问题就是如果这些声音是真实的，那么它们是什么？鲁昂的审讯者不可能接受贞德坚持认为它们是来自天堂的起源，因为当然，这是一场政治审判，如果他们接受这些声音是来自天堂的起源，
then that is immediately to destroy the legitimacy of the Lancasterian regime that they are serving. Equally, though, to condemn the voices as satanic, raises its own issues. And the inquisitors are learned men and a lot of them are honest men. And they are troubled by the question of whether it is actually heretical to be deceived by Satan. Because, you know, humans are fallen. We are all in a sense deceived by Satan. Satan is very powerful. Like, it's not your fault if Satan gets his teeth into you. And so another example of how this isn't just a kangaroo court, opinion among the assessors on this
那么这立即摧毁了他们所服务的兰开斯特政权的合法性。然而，同样，谴责这些声音为撒旦的，也会引发它自己的问题。审讯者是博学的人，他们中的许多人是诚实的人。他们被是否被撒旦欺骗实际上是异端的问题所困扰。因为，你知道，人类是堕落的。我们都在某种意义上被撒旦欺骗了。撒旦非常强大。就像，如果撒旦咬住你，那不是你的错。所以这是这不仅仅是一个袋鼠法庭的另一个例子，评估员对这个问题的意见
issue is split and one of the theologians actually says, well, you know, this is above our pay grade. I think we should really go and consult the Pope. And of course, Caution and definitely Warwick is having none of that. You know, we can't afford to involve the Pope in this. That would be terrible. So it's a bit of a nightmare for Caution. And what he really needs is for Joan simply to confess her errors and recant because that would cut the whole Gordian knot. And so he and his fellow judges focus on two particular aspects of Joan's testimony. And he and his fellow judges focus on two particular aspects of Joan's testimony. And they've obviously kind of sniffed these two areas as being the ones where Joan is most vulnerable. And the first of these, people may remember at Tor, the Dofant had asked Joan
分歧很大，其中一位神学家实际上说，好吧，你知道，这超出了我们的职权范围。我认为我们真的应该去咨询教皇。当然，科雄和沃里克绝对不会那样做。你知道，我们负担不起让教皇参与其中。那将是可怕的。所以这对科雄来说有点像噩梦。他真正需要的是贞德简单地承认她的错误并撤回，因为那将切断整个戈尔迪之结。所以他和他的法官同僚专注于贞德证词的两个特定方面。他们显然已经嗅到了这两个领域是贞德最脆弱的地方。第一个，人们可能记得在图尔，王储曾问贞德
for a sign to reassure him that she really was who she said she was. She really had been sent by God. And you didn't tell us what this sign was. You kept this a secret, Tom. Right. And that is because Joan wanted to keep it a secret herself. She had been throughout the course of the trial, exceedingly reluctant to reveal it. And she kept insisting, I have promised to keep this a secret. She doesn't actually say who to. I think the Inquisitors assume that she had promised her voices.
要一个标志来让他放心，她确实是她说的那个人。她确实是被上帝派来的。你没有告诉我们这个标志是什么，你把它保密了，汤姆。对。这是因为贞德自己想把它保密。在审判过程中，她极其不愿透露它。她一直坚持，我答应过要把它保密。她实际上没有说对谁。我认为审讯者假设她答应了她的声音。
But it may be that she'd promised Charles the 7th. We don't know. Anyway, finally, she just gets worn down and she reveals the truth. And she says that an angel had appeared and had brought the dofant a crown of purest gold. The angel appeared to her and to the dofair. and to the Dofa and to the court. Everyone in the court?
但可能是她答应了查理七世。我们不知道。总之，最后，她只是被磨垮了，她揭示了真相。她说一位天使出现了，并带给王储一个纯金的皇冠。天使出现在她和王储面前。出现在王储和法庭面前。法庭上的每个人？
Everyone in the court, yes. Okay. That this angel had been accompanied by a host of other angels and also by St. Catherine and by St. Margaret. What, they're all crowded into the council chamber or whatever? Well, Joan will later specify that they were very small. I mean, I think she's implying that they're kind of shaded away into a different dimension. Throughout her account of this, she is obviously really struggling to make sense of something that she feels is real, but can't put into words. However, these are the words that she gives.
法庭上的每个人，是的。好的。这位天使还有一群其他天使，以及圣凯瑟琳和圣玛格丽特陪同。什么，他们都挤在议事厅还是什么地方？嗯，贞德后来会说明他们非常小。我的意思是，我认为她在暗示他们以某种方式隐入了一个不同的维度。在她对这件事的整个叙述中，她显然非常努力地想要理解她认为真实但又无法用言语表达的事情。然而，这就是她给出的说法。
she then says that the angel had given the crown to the Archbishop of Rass and that the Archbishop had then given it to the king and I see your expression it's one of disbelief and dare I say contempt well you were not alone because the theologians listening to this they just say this is mad this is ridiculous and there's one particular one from Paris who says this is a presumptuous misleading and pernicious falsehood a fabricated matter that diminishes the dignity of angels I mean, that's my objection to it, actually, that it diminishes the dignity of angels.
然后她说，天使把王冠交给了拉斯大主教，大主教又把它交给了国王。我看到你的表情了，那是怀疑，甚至可以说是不屑。嗯，你并不孤单，因为听着这些的神学家们只会说这太疯狂了，这太荒谬了。巴黎有一位特别的神学家说，这是狂妄、误导和有害的谎言，是捏造的事实，贬低了天使的尊严。我的意思是，这其实也是我对此的反对意见，它贬低了天使的尊严。
You would have served well on the bench of assessors at Joan's trial. I think I'd be a brilliant inquisitor, to be honest. So the other issue, of course, is this perennial problem of her male clothing. And the reason is because it opens Joan up to a very obvious accusation. Joan says that essentially she is wearing her clothes, her male clothes, because the voices want her to wear them. However, this is in direct contradiction to the teachings of the church. So essentially, Joan is placing the testimony of her voices above that of the church, and this is palpably heretical. She hasn't got a leg to stand on here, basically, not even a leg of male hose. It also, of course,
你在贞德审判的陪审席上会表现得很好。老实说，我觉得我会成为一名出色的宗教裁判官。所以，另一个问题当然是她穿男装这个长期存在的问题。原因在于，这让贞德面临一个非常明显的指控。贞德基本上说，她穿男装是因为那些声音要求她穿。然而，这与教会的教义直接矛盾。所以本质上，贞德把她听到的声音的证词置于教会之上，这显然是异端邪说。她基本上站不住脚，甚至连男式长袜的腿都站不住。当然，这也……
in the opinion of her assessors, demonstrates that the voices are indeed satanic, because the voices would not be instructing her to do something that is against biblical instructions. So that also is something where they feel Joan is on a very sticky wicket. So on the 23rd of May, those two charges, the fact that she made up rubbish about, you know, the sign that she gave Charles of 7th and the fact that she insists on wearing male clothing, together with 10 other charges, among which is the proposition that by jumping out of the 60 foot tower, she'd been trying to commit suicide rather than escape and kind of various other items like that. These are presented to Joan. She's told that in the opinion of her judges, these charges satisfy them that she is indeed a heretic. And her judges require her to confess and to repent all these faults if she is to be spared. Right.
在她的陪审员看来，这证明了那些声音确实是撒旦的，因为那些声音不会指示她做违背圣经教导的事情。所以这也是他们觉得贞德处境非常尴尬的一点。因此，在5月23日，那两项指控——她编造了关于她给查理七世的那个标志的废话，以及她坚持穿男装的事实——连同其他10项指控，其中包括她试图从60英尺高的塔上跳下，是为了自杀而不是逃跑，以及其他各种类似的项目。这些都被提交给了贞德。她被告知，在她的法官看来，这些指控足以证明她确实是一个异端。如果她想被宽恕，她的法官要求她忏悔并悔改所有这些错误。好吧。
And she doesn't, does she? For my words and deeds mentioned in this trial, I refer to them and I wish to stand by them. So she's going to stick to her guns. She's not going to change her gene now. she's still standing strong. So the next day, a tumbril is brought to the foot of her tower. Joan is led down. She's put into the tumbrill,
她没有，对吧？对于我在这次审判中提到的言行，我坚持我的说法，我希望坚持到底。所以她要坚持自己的立场。她现在不会改变她的基因。她依然立场坚定。所以第二天，一辆囚车被带到她塔楼的脚下。贞德被带了下来。她被放进囚车，
and the tumbril then rattles through the streets of Rouen to an abbey in the centre of the town where there is a cemetery, and this is the largest open space in the city, and thousands have gathered there, and they are gathered around a huge wooden stage on which Couchon is sitting, his fellow judge, the Dominican, all the various other assessors from Jones trial,
然后囚车在鲁昂的街道上嘎吱作响，驶向市中心的一座修道院，那里有一个墓地，这是城里最大的空地，成千上万的人聚集在那里，他们聚集在一个巨大的木制舞台周围，考雄坐在上面，他的同僚法官，多米尼加人，以及贞德审判中的所有其他陪审员，
and a host of ecclesiastical luminaries of whom the leading figure is a genuine cardinal, the only English cardinal at the time, a guy called Henry Beaufort, who is also, he's the richest man in England, and he is the great uncle of Henry the 6th. So a very serious player indeed. Warwick, of course, is also, you know, he's come to a, watch. The Duke of Bedford is not there. He is absent in Paris, but of course he is keeping a very close eye on proceedings as well. So Joan is led to a scaffold and she has been, she's stood there to hear her sentence. Before the sentence is delivered, however, a theologian comes forward,
还有一大群教会名流，其中领头的是一位真正的红衣主教，当时唯一的英国红衣主教，一个叫亨利·博福特的人，他也是英国最富有的人，他是亨利六世的叔祖父。所以确实是一个非常重要的人物。沃里克当然也来了，你知道，他来看热闹。贝德福德公爵不在。他缺席在巴黎，但当然他也非常密切地关注着诉讼程序。所以贞德被带到脚手架上，她站在那里听取判决。然而，在判决宣布之前，一位神学家走上前来，
joins her on the scaffold and delivers a sermon and his text is, a branch cannot bear fruit of itself unless it remain in the vine. In other words, someone who detaches herself from the vine of the church is asking to be consigned to the fire. I mean, that's the subtext. Joan listens to the sermon. She still refuses to confess, and so Couchon rises to his feet, and he delivers his judgment, which is that the accused is a heretic, and therefore, like a withered vine, should be cast out of Holy Church, and handed to the secular arm,
在脚手架上加入她并发表了一篇布道，他的经文是，枝子若不常在葡萄树上，自己就不能结果子。换句话说，一个将自己从教会的葡萄树上分离出来的人，就是在请求被送入火中。我的意思是，这就是潜台词。贞德听着布道。她仍然拒绝忏悔，于是考雄站起身来，宣布了他的判决，即被告是异端，因此，就像一根枯萎的葡萄树，应该被逐出圣教会，并移交给世俗权力，
which in effect is Warwick and the English. And the executioner is standing by outside the cemetery, so beyond the consecrated ground of the abbey, a great bonfire has been prepared, the stake has been erected, everything is ready to go, the sentence is that Joan is to be burned alive, consumed by the purifying flames of fire.
实际上就是沃里克和英国人。行刑者站在墓地外面，也就是在修道院的神圣土地之外，一个巨大的篝火堆已经准备好了，火刑柱已经竖立起来，一切准备就绪，判决是贞德将被活活烧死，被净化之火吞噬。
So the end is approaching Tom, but is there a twist? There is Dominic. Because as Couchon is saying this, suddenly, unexpectedly, Joan rises to her feet. And Couchon is so surprised by this that he hesitates. And as he hesitates, Joan raises her voice again. And she declares to the astonishment of everyone gathered there that she is going to submit to the church and her judges. after all. She is going to abjure her visions and revelations, and she repeats this over and over again.
所以结局临近了，汤姆，但会有转折吗？有的，多米尼克。因为当考雄说这些话时，贞德突然出人意料地站了起来。考雄对此感到非常惊讶，以至于他犹豫了。就在他犹豫的时候，贞德再次提高了嗓门。她令聚集在那里的所有人感到震惊的是，她宣布她毕竟还是要服从教会和她的法官。她要放弃她的幻象和启示，她一遍又一遍地重复这一点。
Joan the maid, at the very last moment, has been brought to submit. Gricky, what a twist. Come back after the break to find out what happens next. Welcome back to the rest is history. What an extraordinary twist. So after all that, after all her defiance at the trial, Joan of Arc to the astonishment of her judges of the Bishop of Beauvais, Mr. Couchon, and everybody else who has gathered in the centre of ruin to see her condemnation to the flames, she has just recanted, obdured her sins. And Couchon, who expected her to go down fighting, is so stunned by this, isn't he, that he doesn't know what to say. Yeah, and so he turns to Cardinal Beaufort and says, well,
贞德，这位少女，在最后一刻被带去服从了。天哪，真是个转折。休息后回来看看接下来会发生什么。欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。真是个非凡的转折。所以经过这一切，经过她在审判中的所有反抗，圣女贞德令她的法官们、博韦主教考雄先生以及聚集在鲁昂市中心观看她被判火刑的所有人都感到震惊，她刚刚撤回了她的言论，放弃了她的罪行。而本以为她会抗争到底的考雄，对此感到如此震惊，不是吗，以至于他不知道该说什么。是的，于是他转向博福特红衣主教说，好吧，
What on earth do I do now? And Beaufort replies that Joan has spoken out as a penitent. And so therefore there can be no question of handing her over to the secular arm. In other words, Warwick and the English guards. And instead she should be classed back into the bosom of Mother Church. And this, I think, is a big reassurance to Kosha. Because, of course, Beaufort, you know, he's not just a cardinal. So he knows what he's talking about on the theological dimension.
我现在到底该怎么办？博福特回答说，贞德已经以忏悔者的身份发言了。因此，根本不可能把她移交给世俗权力。换句话说，沃里克和英国卫兵。相反，她应该被重新纳入圣母教会的怀抱。我认为，这对考雄来说是一个巨大的安慰。因为，当然，博福特，你知道，他不仅仅是一位红衣主教。所以他在神学层面上知道他在说什么。
But he is also the great uncle of Henry the 6th. so he can be presumed to be speaking for the English establishment at the same time. And so Cauthoor, you know, he's got the backing of the cardinal. So he stands up and he orders that Joan's abjuration be drawn up in the form of a document. And this document obliges Joan specifically to acknowledge that she had been the dupe of evil spirits. And the emphasis on that word dupe. So she is not admitting to witchcraft, but she is publicly stating that, she had been tricked by satanic forces when she led Charles the 7th to his coronation in Arras.
但他也是亨利六世的叔祖父。所以可以推测他同时也代表了英国当权派。所以考雄，你知道，他得到了红衣主教的支持。于是他站起来，命令将贞德的放弃以文件的形式起草出来。这份文件特别要求贞德承认她一直是被邪灵愚弄的受害者。重点在于“受害者”这个词。所以她并没有承认巫术，但她公开声明，当她带领查理七世去阿拉斯加冕时，她被撒旦的力量欺骗了。
And this, in the opinion of Couchon, is sufficient. Job done. You know, he's got his result. Right. So she wasn't colluding with evil. She was deluded by evil. That's an important, important difference, isn't it? Yes.
在考雄看来，这就足够了。工作完成了。你知道，他得到了他的结果。好吧。所以她没有与邪恶勾结。她是被邪恶欺骗了。这是一个重要、重要的区别，不是吗？是的。
And so this abjuration is then brought to Joan and she marks it with a cross. And Cauton now delivers his sentence on the penitent. first of all he releases her from the bonds of her excommunication but then in the very next sentence he delivers a crushing blow which obviously stuns joan who i think was expecting that with her abjuration she would be set free coachon declares because you have rashly sinned against god we condemn you to a salutary penance of perpetual imprisonment with the bread of sorrow and the water of affliction that you may weep there for your faults and joan is then bundledry penance of perpetual imprisonment and joan is then bunnerary penance of perpetent and jane is then bun away and she is led back to her cell where a few hours later she is visited by a delegation of clerics and they bring her a dress, a woman's dress, which she obediently puts on and she is then shaved bald so that all traces of her, you know, her masculine haircut is gone. So a big blow to Joan this because she, I think probably very naively thought that they would just say, oh, well, you know, off you go, well done. But she's going to
于是这份放弃书被带给贞德，她用十字架标记了它。考雄现在对这位忏悔者宣布了他的判决。首先，他解除了她的绝罚，但在下一句话中，他给予了沉重的一击，这显然让贞德惊呆了，我认为她原本以为随着她的放弃，她会被释放。考雄宣布，因为你鲁莽地冒犯了上帝，我们判处你终身监禁的救赎性惩罚，伴随着悲伤的面包和苦难的水，以便你在那里为你的错误哭泣。贞德随后被……（重复）……她被带回牢房，几个小时后，一群神职人员拜访了她，他们给她带来了一件裙子，一件女人的裙子，她顺从地穿上了，然后她被剃光了头，这样她所有男式发型的痕迹都消失了。这对贞德来说是一个巨大的打击，因为我认为她可能非常天真地以为他们只会说，哦，好吧，你可以走了，做得好。但她将
be locked up forever. Now, what do the English High Command think? Because they wanted to make a real example of her because they genuinely believed that she was serving the interests of Satan and supporting the French and hearing her voices and stuff. And now they've been slightly frustrated of their goal, haven't they? Yeah, well, Bedford isn't actually there. But I think there's no question that all along his goal has been to see Joan condemned as a sorceress because her powers of witchcraft are essentially what excuse him his failures. If he can blame the disasters that have overwhelmed the Lancastrian regime in France on sorcery, then in a sense he is absolved of personal failure.
被永远关起来。现在，英国最高指挥部怎么想？因为他们想拿她做一个真正的榜样，因为他们真诚地相信她在为撒旦的利益服务，支持法国人，听从她的声音等等。现在他们有点挫败了他们的目标，不是吗？是的，好吧，贝德福德其实不在那里。但我认为毫无疑问，他一直以来的目标是看到贞德被定罪为女巫，因为她的巫术力量基本上是他失败的借口。如果他能把压垮法国兰开斯特政权的灾难归咎于巫术，那么在某种意义上，他就免除了个人失败的责任。
And this, of course, is a kind of tribute to Joan. It's an acknowledgement that, I suppose, that rather than just being a dupe, you know, she'd been something much more sinister, much more significant, you know, that she personally had been the agent of English misfortunes, which in turn is to cast her as someone kind of special. And I think there's an irony here because for Joan, the sense of herself as someone special, I think that also was, you know, that was very important to her. And I think that in the days that follow her confession, she starts to reflect on this. And she thinks, I've given up this sense of myself as God's medium, as God's messenger, in exchange for life imprisonment.
当然，这算是对贞德的一种致敬。这是一种承认，我想，与其说她只是一个受害者，你知道，她是一个更险恶、更重要的人物，你知道，她个人是英国不幸的代理人，这反过来又把她塑造成一个特别的人。我认为这里有一种讽刺，因为对于贞德来说，她认为自己是一个特别的人，我认为这也，你知道，这对她非常重要。我认为在她忏悔后的几天里，她开始反思这一点。她想，我放弃了作为上帝媒介、上帝信使的自我意识，换取了终身监禁。
is that a reasonable exchange? And so she falls to you know, well, to pondering her future. Yeah, she's given up
这是一个合理的交换吗？于是她陷入了……你知道，嗯，思考她的未来。是的，她放弃了
her identity, right, as she sees it. She's given up what made her special and now she's bitterly regretting it because she's just
她的身份，对吧，正如她所看到的那样。她放弃了让她变得特别的东西，现在她对此感到痛苦地后悔，因为她只是
sitting there in prison and that will be her reality for the rest of her life. And she's betrayed her king and I think most crucially of all she has portrayed her voices. And so four days after
坐在监狱里，那将是她余生的现实。她背叛了她的国王，我认为最关键的是，她背叛了她的声音。所以四天后
her recantation, ominous news has brought to Couchon and to Warwick that Joan has put her male clothes back on. When her assessors come to see her, she gives various reasons for doing this. First of all, she claims that she was tricked into swearing never again to wear men's clothes, that she hadn't realised that was what she was doing.
她撤回言论后，考雄和沃里克得到了不祥的消息，贞德又穿回了男装。当她的陪审员来看她时，她给出了各种理由。首先，她声称她被骗发誓永远不再穿男装，她没有意识到她当时在做什么。
She then, I think, also strongly implies that her guards were sexually abusing her. So to quote the record of the clerk who was taking the minutes, that being among men, she thought that wearing men's clothes was more lawful and appropriate, than wearing women's. And she also declared that she would rather die than spend her entire life, you know, fettered, living on bread and water. And so her judges, I think, are clearly stunned by this.
然后，我认为，她还强烈暗示她的守卫在性虐待她。所以引用记录员的记录，因为身处男人之中，她认为穿男装比穿女装更合法、更合适。她还宣称，她宁愿死也不愿终身被束缚，靠面包和水生活。所以她的法官，我认为，显然对此感到震惊。
And they say to her, well, you know, if this was the case, why ever did you confess? Why ever did you abjure? And then comes, I think, the most touching moment in the whole story of Joan. She answers very simply, and it brings home to you, this is a teenage girl. She says, I did it for fear of the fire.
他们对她说，好吧，你知道，如果真是这样，你为什么要忏悔？你为什么要放弃？然后出现了，我认为，贞德整个故事中最感人的时刻。她回答得非常简单，它让你意识到，这是一个十几岁的女孩。她说，我这样做是因为害怕火。
And I kind of find it heart-rending. And perhaps even at this late moment, she might still have saved herself. But then comes the straw that breaks the inquisitorial back. Again, to quote the clerk, he's been taking the minutes. She was asked whether she had heard the voices of St. Catherine and St. Margaret since the last Thursday, which is when she had repented. She said yes. Oh, no.
我觉得这令人心碎。也许即使在这一刻，她本可以自救。但随后出现了压垮宗教裁判所的最后一根稻草。再次引用记录员的话，他一直在做记录。她被问及自上周四（她忏悔的那天）以来是否听到了圣凯瑟琳和圣玛格丽特的声音。她说听到了。哦，不。
She's back on the voices again. And the clerk then later scribbled in the moment. margin of the minutes, this single comment. Responsio mortiferra, a fatal reply, the reply that is going to kill her. Right, because the very next day, the 29th of May, Couchon gathers his experts in theology and canon and civil law. They meet in the Archbishop's residence in Rouen, and their verdict is unanimous, isn't it? Joan is now very, she has outed herself very clearly in defiance of the court and of their opinion as a heretic. Yes.
她又回到那些声音了。记录员后来在会议记录的页边空白处潦草地写下了这条评论。Responsio mortiferra，致命的回答，那个将要杀死她的回答。对，因为第二天，5月29日，考雄召集了他的神学、教会法和民法专家。他们在鲁昂的大主教官邸会面，他们的判决是一致的，不是吗？贞德现在非常清楚地表明了她对法庭和他们意见的蔑视，是一个异端。是的。
And so that being so, the church washes her hands of her, and they decree that she is unregenerate and therefore excommunicate and therefore to be handed over to the secular power. And the next day early in the morning, very early in the morning, one last deputation of clerics come to visit her. And you can imagine how thrilling that must be for Joan on her last day. Yeah, another load of clerics. and Joan talks to them in very muted, very despondent tones as well she might have done.
既然如此，教会就洗手不干了，他们宣布她不可救药，因此被逐出教会，因此要移交给世俗权力。第二天清晨，非常清晨，最后一批神职人员代表团来拜访她。你可以想象这对贞德在最后一天来说是多么令人激动。是的，又是一堆神职人员。贞德以非常低沉、非常沮丧的语气与他们交谈，正如她可能做的那样。
And you can see what she's been thinking about from the topics that she brings up. So her thoughts are still very much on Charles the 7th and that sign that she had given him. And you can tell that she has been turning it over in her mind, that she's really been struggling to make sense of what precisely had happened. And she says that, yes, there had been an angel who had given the dophan a crown, but that angel she now says had been herself. That's a mad thing to say. Do you think?
你可以从她提出的主题中看出她在想什么。所以她的心思仍然非常集中在查理七世和她给他的那个标志上。你可以看出她一直在脑海中反复思考，她真的在努力理解到底发生了什么。她说，是的，确实有一位天使给了王储一顶王冠，但她现在说那位天使就是她自己。这真是一件疯狂的事情。你觉得呢？
She's gone from saying the room was packed with angels who were two feet tall to saying actually I was the angel. I think to say I was the angel is high risk. I think that it was a very intense moment for her. I mean, who knows what was going on. But definitely she felt that something had happened and that she is trying to make sense of it still in her very last hours. And then of course she speaks of her voices
她从说房间里挤满了两英尺高的天使，变成了说其实我就是那个天使。我认为说我就是那个天使是高风险的。我认为这对她来说是一个非常激烈的时刻。我的意思是，谁知道发生了什么。但毫无疑问，她觉得发生了一些事情，并且她在最后的时刻仍然试图理解它。然后当然，她谈到了她的声音，
and she declares whether they are good or evil speech. spirits, they appeared to me. So that suggests a degree of doubt that she's wobbling again? I don't think she's wobbling, but that she loves them and she's going to stay loyal to them, even if, you know, at the cost of being burnt to death. Okay. So then a friar enters the cell and he hears Joan's confession. And then throughout this, the term of her imprisonment, Joan has been denied communion,
她宣称无论它们是好是坏，它们都向我显现了。这是否暗示她又动摇了？我不认为她在动摇，而是她爱它们，她会保持忠诚，即使，你知道，以被烧死为代价。好的。然后一位修士进入牢房，听取了贞德的忏悔。在整个监禁期间，贞德一直被拒绝领圣餐，
being denied the Eucharist, and she has a great devotion to the Eucharist. And so this has been a source of great distress to her. and now I think a gesture of mercy on Caution's part, he allows her to have communion. So that's nice of him. Oh, that's kind. It's now 9 o'clock, and it is the morning of the 30th of May 1431, and Joan is brought from her cell. She's weeping. She is surrounded by a large squad of English soldiers, and they escort her from the castle to the Market Square in Ruin,
被拒绝领圣体，而她对圣体有极大的虔诚。所以这对她来说是一个巨大的痛苦来源。现在我认为考雄表现出了一种仁慈，他允许她领圣餐。那对他来说真不错。哦，那很仁慈。现在是1431年5月30日的上午9点，贞德被带出牢房。她在哭泣。她被一大队英国士兵包围，他们护送她从城堡到鲁昂的市场广场，
where inevitably a huge crowd, they've picked up on the news, they've gathered. Joan is in male clothes, so she's not forced into a dress. And on her head, she wears a kind of a cap like kind of old-fashioned Dunce's cap. It's inscribed with the words heretic, relapse, apostate, idolater. So that's all bad news. And basically the format on this morning is the same as it had been six days previously. So a sermon is given and then Couchon reads out the sentence, but this time Joan keeps silent. the sentence is delivered and accepted.
那里不可避免地聚集了大量人群，他们听到了消息。贞德穿着男装，所以她没有被迫穿裙子。她的头上戴着一种像老式笨蛋帽的帽子。上面写着“异端、重犯、叛教者、偶像崇拜者”。所以这都是坏消息。基本上，那天早上的形式和六天前一样。所以布道开始了，然后考雄宣读了判决，但这次贞德保持沉默。判决被传达并接受了。
And Joan is then handed over to the English guards who remove her up to the top of an immense bonfire. And Joan is weeping and she requests crucifix and an English guard with a kind of display of mercy, of kindness, of sympathy, gives her a makeshift crucifix. And Joan hugs it to her chest as she is then chained and bound to the stake. and the fire is lit and the smoke begins to rise and Joan her lips had been moving in silent prayer throughout and then people in the crowd hear her cry out through the smoke Jesus Jesus Jesus and in due course decades later
然后贞德被移交给英国卫兵，他们把她带到巨大的篝火堆顶上。贞德在哭泣，她请求十字架，一名英国卫兵带着一种仁慈、善良、同情的表现，给了她一个临时十字架。当她被锁住并绑在火刑柱上时，贞德把它紧紧抱在胸前。火被点燃了，烟雾开始升起，贞德的嘴唇在整个过程中一直在默默祈祷，然后人群中的人们听到她在烟雾中呼喊：耶稣，耶稣，耶稣。在随后的几十年里，
lots of stories would be told of her death so there's a story that a priest had rushed to a nearby church and had brought out a crucifix from there on a great kind of pole and held it up before her for as long as she could see it until the smoke blotted it out, that the executioner, that one of the English soldiers, even Cardinal Beaufort himself, had wept to watch her fate, and that her heart, no matter how repeatedly the fire was stoked,
关于她的死会有很多故事流传：有一个故事说，一位牧师冲进附近的一座教堂，从那里拿出一个十字架，放在一根大杆子上，在她还能看到的时候一直举着它，直到烟雾遮住了它；还有人说，其中一名英国士兵，甚至博福特红衣主教本人，在看到她的命运时都流下了眼泪；还有人说，无论火被拨弄多少次，她的心脏
refused to burn. And again, people can make of those stories what they will. But of one thing, there is no doubt. Once the embers had cooled, her ashes were swept up and they were dumped unceremoniously into the Sen. So six and a half months after that in Paris, in Notre Dame, no less,
都拒绝燃烧。同样，人们可以随心所欲地解读这些故事。但有一点是毫无疑问的。余烬冷却后，她的骨灰被扫起，毫不客气地倾倒在塞纳河中。所以六个半月后，在巴黎，在圣母院，
Henry the 6th was crowned as Henry II of France. Now, meanwhile, in the court of Charles V, the 7th, the rival court, has Joan been turned into a martyr? Have there been howls of protest? Has her death become a symbol of suffering of the sanctity of France violated by the English? No, they don't make anything of Joan at all. Isn't that extraordinary that Charles the 7th who owes her so much,
亨利六世被加冕为法国国王亨利二世。现在，与此同时，在查理七世的宫廷里，那个敌对的宫廷，贞德被变成烈士了吗？有抗议的呼声吗？她的死是否成为了法国神圣性被英国人践踏的痛苦象征？不，他们根本没有利用贞德。查理七世欠她这么多，这难道不非凡吗？
basically acts as though she never existed? Well, is it extraordinary? I'm not sure it is because Joan has become a huge embarrassment. And, you know, she is now a condemned heretic. So Charles the 7th Charles the 7th wants to keep very very quiet about it But the thing is people do not forget about her She remains very much an emblem of French resistance
基本上表现得好像她从未存在过一样？嗯，这非凡吗？我不确定，因为贞德已经成了一个巨大的尴尬。而且，你知道，她现在是一个被定罪的异端。所以查理七世想对此保持非常、非常安静。但问题是，人们并没有忘记她。她仍然是法国抵抗运动的象征，
Despite her fate And her death does not lead to a revival of Lancasterian fortunes And the coronation of Henry in Notre Dame Does not blot out the memory of how Charles the 7th with Joan at his side had been crowned in Rance. And the continuing silence of Charles the 7th, the ungrateful silence of Charles the 7th, one might say,
尽管她的命运如此。她的死并没有导致兰开斯特王朝命运的复兴。亨利在圣母院的加冕礼并没有抹去查理七世在贞德的陪伴下在兰斯加冕的记忆。而查理七世持续的沉默，人们可能会说，查理七世忘恩负义的沉默，
his refusal so much as to mention the name of this peasant girl who had done so much to save him from ruin. This doesn't mean that Charles has forgotten, Joan. And actually, in due course, 19 years after she had been burnt to death in Rouen in February 1450, finally Charles does speak her name and he says a long time ago Jean Lapucel was taken and captured by our ancient enemies and adversaries for the English and brought to the city of Rouen and the reason that Charles feels able to speak her name at last is because since Jones death and 1450 so much has changed so to go through some of the the bullet points in 1435 the Duke of Burgundy, Philip the Good, who for so long had been resolute in his refusal to reach terms with the guy who he blamed for murdering his father, namely Charles the 7th. He does come to terms with Charles de 7th and a pact is signed between France and Burgundy and this effectively leaves the English alone.
他拒绝提及这个为拯救他免于毁灭而做了这么多的农家女孩的名字。这并不意味着查理忘记了贞德。事实上，在鲁昂被烧死19年后，即1450年2月，查理终于说出了她的名字，他说很久以前，贞德被我们的古老敌人和对手英国人俘虏，并被带到鲁昂市。查理之所以觉得终于可以提起她的名字，是因为自贞德去世到1450年，发生了很多变化。所以回顾一下要点：1435年，勃艮第公爵菲利普好人，长期以来一直坚决拒绝与他指责谋杀他父亲的人（即查理七世）达成协议。他确实与查理七世达成了协议，法国和勃艮第之间签署了一项条约，这实际上让英国人孤立无援。
Following year, Charles 7th enters Paris. He has reclaimed the capital of France. 1440, a real straw in the wind. the English are so desperate to try and patch up terms that they allow the Duke of Ornion, who'd been kept as a prisoner in England since the Battle of Agincourt, they allow him to come home back to France. And his captivity had been the longest of any prisoner in the entire history of the Hundred Years' War. And then in 1449, Charles 7th embarks on the conquest of Normandy. And in November 1449, so that is four months before he finally mentions the name of Joan of Arc, he had entered Rouen
第二年，查理七世进入巴黎。他收复了法国的首都。1440年，一个真正的风向标。英国人非常绝望地试图修补条款，以至于他们允许奥尔良公爵（自阿金库尔战役以来一直被关押在英国）回家回到法国。他的囚禁是百年战争史上所有囚犯中最长的。然后在1449年，查理七世开始了对诺曼底的征服。1449年11月，也就是他最终提到圣女贞德名字的前四个月，他进入了鲁昂，
the capital of English Normandy and he does so beneath the fluttering of the standard of St Michael, the Archangel. And by his side, his greatest captain is with him. And this is the man who is no longer known as the bastard of Ornion, but
英国诺曼底的首府，他是在大天使圣迈克尔旗帜的飘扬下进入的。在他身边，他最伟大的统帅与他在一起。这就是那个不再被称为奥尔良私生子的人，而是
since 1939 as the Count of Du Noir, the guy who had been at Joan's side at her greatest triumph at the relief of the siege of Orleon. So it's now when they reclaim Rouen 19 years later, that they finally address the issue of Joan and her treatment by the English. And this is the point at which Charles V, basically, I guess he kind of institutionalises the idea
自1939年以来被称为迪努瓦伯爵的人，那个在贞德最伟大的胜利——奥尔良之围解围时站在她身边的人。所以现在，当他们在19年后收复鲁昂时，他们终于解决了贞德及其受到英国人对待的问题。这就是查理七世基本上，我想他某种程度上制度化了这种想法的时刻，
that Joan was a martyr destroyed by a kangaroo court. Yes, so again, you know, this proclamation that he issues in February 1450, the English had tried Joan by certain persons who had been chosen and given this task by them, and during this trial they made and committed several errors and abuses, such that by means of this trial in the great hatred that our enemy had against her, they had her put to death very cruelly, iniquitously and against reason. And you can see why Charles is now saying this, because if he can have that original verdict scrubbed,
即贞德是一位被袋鼠法庭摧毁的烈士。是的，所以同样，你知道，他在1450年2月发布的这份公告，英国人通过某些被他们选中并赋予这项任务的人审判了贞德，在这次审判中，他们犯下并实施了若干错误和滥用，以至于通过这次审判以及我们的敌人对她怀有的巨大仇恨，他们非常残忍、不公正且违背理性地将她处死。你可以看出查理现在为什么要这么说，因为如果他能抹去最初的判决，
then that is a real help in legitimising his own coronation. And Charles XIV does what leaders do today when they want something done. They institute a public inquiry. And for the next six years, a succession of these inquiries, these inquiries, these inquests, these reports are delivered and they culminate in an official retrial and they sift through all the details of Joan's life and all the details of her death. And it has to be said that while this is going on on the public stage of France, great events continue to happen.
那么这对使他自己的加冕礼合法化确实有很大帮助。查理七世做了当今领导人在想要完成某事时会做的事情。他们设立了一个公开调查。在接下来的六年里，一系列的调查、报告被提交，最终导致了正式的重审，他们仔细审查了贞德生活和死亡的所有细节。必须说，当这一切在法国的公共舞台上进行时，伟大的事件继续发生。
And these events serve as a reminder to everyone in France that Joan, you know, she'd said that she would relieve the siege of all you or she did. she said that she would crown Charles the 7th and she did and she had said that the English would be, to quote her, kicked out of France. You know, by 1456 when the retrial is staged, that has come true. So in 1450, the French complete their conquest of Normandy. In 1451, Gascany in the southwest of France, so Bordeaux and all of that, you know, it'd been a possession of the English crown for 300 years by this point. The French take that back. 1453, the old war dog Sir John Talbot, you know, the guy who'd been fighting at
这些事件提醒法国的每个人，贞德，你知道，她说她会解除奥尔良之围，她做到了；她说她会加冕查理七世，她做到了；她说英国人会被，引用她的话，踢出法国。你知道，到1456年重审举行时，这一切都实现了。所以1450年，法国人完成了对诺曼底的征服。1451年，法国西南部的加斯科涅，也就是波尔多等等，你知道，到那时它已经是英国王室的领地300年了。法国人收复了它。1453年，老战犬约翰·塔尔博特爵士，你知道，那个在
at Orlyor, who'd been captured at Paté, who had remained the most menacing of all the English captains resisting the French. He gets killed, his army gets wiped out in Gascany by French artillery. It's a very symbolic moment. You know, the Longbowmen are superseded. The age of English military supremacy has gone. And in effect, the death of Torbett at the Battle of Castignon in 1453 marks the end of the 100 years war. And of all the many conquests of Edward III of Henry 5th, there is only one tiny fragment of France that remains to England and that of course is Calais. And even that will be lost a century later in the reign of Mary Tudor. Of course. But the real moment that sets the seal on France is very very,
奥尔良战斗过，在帕泰被俘，一直是最具威胁性的抵抗法国人的英国统帅。他被杀，他的军队在加斯科涅被法国炮兵消灭。这是一个非常有象征意义的时刻。你知道，长弓手被取代了。英国军事霸权的时代结束了。实际上，塔尔博特在1453年卡斯蒂永战役中的死亡标志着百年战争的结束。在爱德华三世和亨利五世的所有众多征服中，只有一小块法国领土留给了英国，那当然是加来。即使是那块领土也会在一个世纪后在玛丽·都铎统治时期丢失。当然。但真正为法国盖棺定论的时刻是非常、非常，
victory comes in July 1456, the 7th of July doesn't only, it comes in the palace of the Archbishop of Rouen. And this is the day that the judges who have been appointed to review Joan of Arc, Jean-La Pussel's trial, that they meet to announce the results of their inquiry. Yeah, and they have, you know, they've consulted a great number of people. So people who've known Joan, everyone from, from Joan's mother to Dunois, the Bastard of Orleans, and the Duke of Alonso, You know, people remember, you know, her biggest dukeal fan. They'd all given evidence. Of course, one person who had not given evidence was another of her comrades in arms,
胜利出现在1456年7月，7月7日，它出现在鲁昂大主教的宫殿里。这一天，被任命审查圣女贞德审判的法官们会面宣布他们调查的结果。是的，他们已经咨询了大量的人。所以认识贞德的人，从贞德的母亲到迪努瓦（奥尔良私生子）和阿朗松公爵，你知道，人们记得，你知道，她最大的公爵粉丝。他们都提供了证据。当然，有一个没有提供证据的人是她的另一位战友，
Gilles de Rey, the Breton guerrilla leader. And that was because he had been executed in 1440 on a charge of heresy and of raping and murdering. And I quote the charge sheet, 140 or more children. Yeah, not a good guy. He's an embarrassment. The veil is drawn over here. him. So what's the verdict of the judges? They announced that Jones' original conviction had been invalid, that it had been delivered corruptly, deceitfully, slanderously, fraudulently and maliciously.
吉尔·德·雷，布列塔尼游击队领袖。那是因为他在1440年因异端罪以及强奸和谋杀罪被处决，我引用指控清单，140多名儿童。是的，不是个好人。他是一个尴尬。面纱被拉过了他。那么法官的判决是什么？他们宣布贞德最初的定罪是无效的，它是腐败、欺骗、诽谤、欺诈和恶意地做出的。
And of course, this not only redeems Jones' own reputation. It also confirms that Charles's coronation in Rance had indeed been ordained by God. And so Joan is no longer condemned as a heretic and she can be inscribed in the annals of French history as the country's greatest heroine and it is a position that she has held ever since right the way up to the present day and next week in a special bonus we will be exploring that legacy and of course if you want to hear that you know what we've got to do you've got to go to the rest is history.com and sign up there But Dominic, before we leave, we have one last duty to perform, and that is to pay tribute to a hero of France whose achievements have been, if anything, even greater than those of Joan of Arc. And who is this paragon? So this is somebody else who came from a very obscure background, Tom, and rose to tremendous heights and dreamt of by his peers. He too has spent years,
当然，这不仅挽回了贞德的名誉。它还证实了查理在兰斯的加冕礼确实是上帝所命定的。所以贞德不再被谴责为异端，她可以被载入法国历史的史册，成为该国最伟大的女英雄，这是她自那时起一直保持到今天的地位。下周，在一个特别的奖励节目中，我们将探讨这一遗产。当然，如果你想听那个，你知道我们必须做什么，你必须去therestisistory.com并注册。但是多米尼克，在我们离开之前，我们还有最后一项职责要履行，那就是向一位法国英雄致敬，他的成就如果说有什么的话，甚至比圣女贞德还要伟大。这位典范是谁？所以这是另一个人，他来自一个非常默默无闻的背景，汤姆，并上升到了巨大的高度，被他的同龄人所梦想。他也花了几年时间，
hearing voices, not the voices of St. Catherine and St. Margaret, but rather more cheerfully, our voices, because this person is Theo Youngsmith, our producer. So he has produced, at my count, at least 450 episodes of the rest is history since you joined the show at the end of 2022. He has run recordings in Ireland, in France, in the Netherlands, in Bosnia-Herzegovina, He's run several live tours of the United States and Australia. He's taken us to New York, to Los Angeles, to Disneyland, and to the Sydney Opera House. He's taken the rest of his history to height we would never have dreamed of when he joined the show. He's been a great friend and comrade to us.
听着声音，不是圣凯瑟琳和圣玛格丽特的声音，而是更令人愉快的声音，我们的声音，因为这个人是西奥·杨史密斯，我们的制片人。所以他制作了，据我统计，自2022年底你加入节目以来，至少450集《历史的其余部分》。他在爱尔兰、法国、荷兰、波斯尼亚和黑塞哥维那进行了录音，他组织了几次美国和澳大利亚的现场巡演。他带我们去了纽约、洛杉矶、迪士尼乐园和悉尼歌剧院。他把《历史的其余部分》带到了我们加入节目时做梦也想不到的高度。他一直是我们伟大的朋友和同志。
He is a credit to Scotland, to France, and of course to Wellington College. And Tom, he will leave. he's moving to spend more time with his Nintendo Switch and he will leave very, very, very big shoes to Phil. So we are tremendously grateful to Theo, aren't we, for the last three years? We are so grateful and we are, you know, we're not a little gutted that he's moving on because he has been so influential on this podcast, has played such a crucial role in its success.
他是苏格兰、法国，当然还有惠灵顿公学的骄傲。汤姆，他要离开了。他要搬去花更多时间陪伴他的任天堂Switch，他将留下非常、非常、非常大的空缺。所以我们非常感谢西奥，不是吗，过去三年？我们非常感激，而且我们，你知道，我们对他要离开感到有点难过，因为他在这个播客上非常有影响力，在它的成功中发挥了如此关键的作用。
And he will, this is not. the last we will be hearing of from Theo because he will be coming on a bonus in due course where he will talk to him about everything he's done with the rest of history and perhaps he will tell us what his plans are because to be honest they are as yet opaque he would also so about six months ago
而且他会，这不是我们最后一次听到西奥的消息，因为他会在适当的时候参加一个奖励节目，在那里他会谈论他与《历史的其余部分》所做的一切，也许他会告诉我们他的计划是什么，因为老实说，它们目前还不透明。他还，大约六个月前
he began work on the famous Stones bonus the Rolling Stones bonus in which he claimed he was he was piling up books in his in his garret and the Stones bonus has never material basically because he's been too busy working on the show. But finally, admittedly, very belatedly, the Rolling Stones bonus will finally materialise.
他开始制作著名的滚石乐队奖励节目，在节目中他声称他正在他的阁楼里堆积书籍，而滚石乐队的奖励节目基本上从未实现，因为他太忙于制作节目了。但最终，诚然，非常迟到了，滚石乐队的奖励节目最终会实现。
So that's something for everybody to look forward to. So two bonuses to come with Theo, one way he talks about himself, which he'll enjoy, and one way he talks to Dominic about the Rolling Stones, which I think he will also enjoy. So everybody, thank you very much for listening. Tom, thank you for four splendid episodes. And above all, Theo, thank you for everything.
所以这是每个人都可以期待的事情。所以有两个关于西奥的奖励节目，一个是他谈论自己，他会喜欢的，另一个是他与多米尼克谈论滚石乐队，我想他也会喜欢的。所以大家，非常感谢你们的收听。汤姆，谢谢你四集精彩的节目。最重要的是，西奥，谢谢你所做的一切。
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。